la paix gwendoline oui oui tout à fait
merci d'être là ben oui ça me fait ch
puis ému quand même
vous avez sait pour l'instant c'est
simple on avait juste à répondre que par
oui ou par non d'accord vous est la
maman d'une personne célèbre wii est ce
que votre fille est actrice
non d'abord s'agit-il d'un
homme ou d'un homme instable cette la
maman d'anne am oui et c'est ce que cet
homme est sur le plateau oui à un rite
et si vous ressemble
ben oui bien sûr qu'en mai et un peu
entorse plateaux vallon là autour de la
table sur le plateau les passions un
plateau de
ces tricots quoi tu crois que ça les
colères son fils c'est quoi non mais
sans déconner est ce que vous êtes fiers
de votre fils oui mais ce que vous avez
la même coupe de cheveux
ça y ressemble un peu est ce que cet
homme est sympathique a tout fait donc
c'est pas bien sa vie
passée vous avez les mêmes dieu bleu
absolument sublime
ouais bah oui à la ceni a dit non a dit
pas tout à fait mais bon oui un peu
enfin bon rock pour ça qu'ils ont ce
éventuellement à mon voisin de droite
est ce que ma maman qui ben
oui aux mains c'est vrai c'est la
roumanie
cherry parce qu'elle a ramené des photos
de guillaume motif
des mini incroyable incroyable
il était sportif guillaume jeune bois et
bien c'est à dire pas trop
mal à digérer un petit peu
je vais adorer le football mais oui
voila moi je
l'appelais carlos tort
[Applaudissements]
c
est ce que est ce que guillaume et jean
zay du foot j'ai du foot et le tour est
joué vous fait jouer car aux subventions
university club voilà alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé l'objet du brevet de
lyon non non mais non mais john bâtés
non non
de la touche il ya prescription c'est
pas grave
mais ils étaient ils étaient stressés
ils étaient stressés donc ils avaient
peur d'être malade donc non mais faut
pas dire ça
je lui ai glissé dans son sac une couche
mais ce n'est pas portée aux
jets vous laissez parler les mamans
thiopet juste
vous avez un truc à lui dire ce soir
peut-être guillaume et voilà c'était la
fête des mamans que si vous a offert
pour leur design voilà ici que
magnifique bouquet
du chocolat
et puis il y avait un petit voyage j'ai
eu un petit peu de pour faire un voyage
et
les tares et la sortir de ces tensions
les tares et là vous êtes va sortir dont
il ya pas d
castanet d'un nouvel hymne et il s'agit
de vous allez je vous réagirez vous
allez allez allez au nom les mêmes
balles et ouvrit mari on y va on en
reste là tout ceci
était devant moi
écouter samedi
[Rires]
regardez yamada lucquois chocolat
chaud que la soirée revenus on va les
voir aller sinon je me dis je vais
prendre des sanctions énormes
assembé novelli non merci à céder
complètement con c'est vraiment la merde
oui c'est à dire si et vous a dépêché la
haye dépêché tout cela jules et qui
votent c'est qui votre chroniqueur
préféré qu'un 1 c'est qui votre 2 2 ici
non pas de la vie
d'ici je regarde pas trop servi
par cyril excusez moi mais moi j'aime
bien
mais un art pendant ces genres dont ça
me touche beaucoup gentil la très belle
madame est ce que pour la fête des mères
on voulait fait une petite danse
peut-être ça vous dérange
non
[Applaudissements]
j'ai très bien avant
je
[Applaudissements]
pour se racheter
à
non
[Applaudissements]
les magnifiques
j'imagine déjà la scène nautique côtière
ce couple recomposé yom il va te dire à
quoi qu'il arrive un jour à berne en
moyenne tension était pas mon père
je fais ce que je veux ok tu vois là
tout de suite c'est pas un jour tu ne
savais pas non mais c'est fou je savais
un petit croche pour bien la balle et là
coup de coeur et beaucoup j'aime
beaucoup celle là c'est plus qu'un
et aux petites salles adorable avec tout
le respect que l'on doit à madame
c'était très agréable diaries tranquille
d'être champion
moi j'ai toujours été fasciné par les
yeux bleus toute façon c'est vraiment ça
me fascine 1 eh oui si perdue pour vous
mais pour elle non mais moi je
suis plutôt content
magnifique en tout cas fait c'est vrai
si l'oncle alors mon niveau school un
dur un dernier truc trop de fils mais
quand est ce que tu viens je trace booba
bientôt attend mon guytou mon guytou
vous l'avez vous l'appelez nitoo oui oui
c'est
pourquoi t'as fait ça ouais de mon
projet elle a fait quoi mais je t'avais
dit d'arrêter de faire ce à quoi à
chaque fois il fait ça le jour elle a
fait ça qu'un serveur ilbo pottas mus
parce que je suis parler de la couche la
revanche quoi ouais je suis comme ça
mais c'est une femme chaleureuse et
adorable
le pc la maman guillaume mais je la
respecte mais je lui dis vous êtes
célibataire ah non non non au célibat
[Rires]
je jugerai g
je ne bougerai jamais j'espère bien
c'est comme l'amour est plus fort que
tous aient bel a beaucoup apprécié ma
barbe elle a dit qu'elle était douce et
beaucoup
sécher qui négligeaient chien aibo mais
il a aussi battu à quelque chose ne va
pas il pouvait pas dire quoi papa il ya
des missions en fait eh ben j'ai regardé
l'émission mais tant mieux il aura vu
grave
moi tout va bien on peut même
recommencer si
elle était d'accord c'était très
agréable et très doux en plus à manger
je n'ai plus ma maman donc je suis très
ému voilà
[Rires]
et l'idée n'avait ni le bon sens c'est
excellent
merci vélo véloce je vais vous dire
juste un truc ça n'est bien sûr pas la
mère de guillaume
c'est une comédienne
c'est la demi soeur de daniel
anodine claudine vous est extra
je suis fan de claudine cette formidable
dit merci d'avoir
[Applaudissements]